Okay.
We have to talk about yesterday's cabinet
meeting.
Donald Trump had a cabinet meeting in front
of the cameras yesterday.
The president's cabinet is a very important
organization entity.
It's part of the executive branch.
There are 23 members, plus the vise president,
15 principal officers, seven other members.
Trump is the chairman of the cabinet.
The cabinet is a really big deal.
And yesterday's cabinet meeting was a veritable
house of horrors freak show.
And I would be doing everybody a disservice
if I pretended that this didn't go down.
So this is going to be a little painful.
But come along with me.
We are going to spend some time today going
through some of what took place yesterday.
Starting with what was a completely insane
moment.
Donald Trump was asked.
Given that minority communities are disproportionately
affected by Corona virus, what specifically
are you doing for them?
Trump didn't answer, and at one point, Trump
essentially listed races and ethnicities.
Take a look at this.
President, you continue to talk about helping
minority communities.
What specifically are you looking at to help
those communities?
What access?
So one of the things I was most proud of was
the minority community and all of the work
we've done for the minority communities, black
unemployment, Hispanic unemployment, Asian
unemployment was the best ever in the history
of our country.
We've never had anything like it.
We've never had so many African-American jobs
ever, ever in the history of our country by
far.
And we are bringing our country back.
And a big focus is exactly that with the minorities
specifically.
If you look at the Asians, they've done incredibly
well.
Hispanics, incredibly well.
African-Americans, a record setting every
month.
You know that every month it was a record
setting jobs number.
Yes.
Black, Hispanic, Asian.
Those certainly exist.
That's.
True, but it's not an answer.
And by the end of this two minute answer,
which I'm not going to subject you to in total.
Donald Trump was talking about completely
unrelated things like ventilators at one point.
Now people often ask, why don't the press
call Trump out and say, you're not answering
the question, you're not answering the question.
The format makes it difficult.
Trump will just move on to the next person.
The microphone gets moved.
He'll call the reporter following up.
You know, a nasty person or call it a nasty
question.
He actually does that a little bit later today.
And if you actually do get to press Trump
on a follow up, he'll just tell three more
lies.
And it genuinely is pretty difficult.
Now, of course, the topic of hydroxy chloroquine
came up the day before yesterday.
Donald Trump claimed that he's been taking
hydroxy chloroquine prophylactically for weeks.
And Donald Trump claims that the best randomized
controlled trial that we have about hydroxy
chloro chloroquine is a fake false study.
Hydroxyl chloroquine should not be used outside
of a hospital setting or.
No, that's what I was told.
Now, there was a false study done where they
gave it to very sick people, extremely sick
people, people that were ready to die.
It was given by obviously not friends of the
administration.
And the study came out that people were ready
to die.
Everybody was old, had bad problems with Hart's
diabetes and everything else you can imagine.
So they gave it so as mediatory when it came
out, they gave a lot of false information.
Just so you understand, great studies came
out of Italy on hydroxy.
You know what I'm talking about.
Right.
So it's true.
It was given to people sick enough to already
be in the hospital.
That is true.
But it was not a fake false study.
It was a proper study.
It had a placebo group.
It had randomization.
It's the best study we have so far.
Now, let me go back to just that last moment
of Trump's answer briefly.
Trump does seem to forget what the drug is
called.
There he seems to glitch.
He says hydroxy and then he has this vacant
look in his eyes.
He seems to forget what he's talking about,
fumbles to recover and asks the reporter if
they know what he's talking about.
Take a look at that moment again.
And just so you understand, great studies
came out of Italy on hydroxy.
You know what I'm talking about.
Right.
Great studies came out.
Really strange stuff for sure.
Trump falling apart completely.
Now, one more glitch here.
Trump said something about DOCSIS.
I guess he was trying to say, doctor, here
ourselves, many, many doctors, doctors, many
doctors came out and they said, it's great.
Now you have to go to a doctor.
OK.
So that one doesn't need too much more discussion.
And then lastly, on hydroxy chloroquine here
is Trump saying that hydroxy chloroquine doesn't
harm anyone, which is untrue.
There are people who have been harmed by taking
this medication.
Is true.
One way or the other, whether you like it
or not.
It's been around for 70 years.
Unbelievably effective for malaria and for
lupus and probably effective for arthritis.
And what has been determined is it doesn't
harm you.
It's a very powerful drug, I guess, but it
doesn't harm you.
And so I thought as a frontline defense, possibly
it would be good.
And I've had no impact from it.
And I've had no I feel the same.
I haven't changed.
I don't think too much.
And at some point, you know, I won't take
it.
Might be soon.
Might be a little bit.
It doesn't it doesn't seem to have any impact
on me, but it seems to be a extra line of
defense.
And it's gotten tremendous reviews from some
people.
He's not a different person as a result of
taking the drug.
That's good to know.
Now, here's a really odd moment.
Treasury Secretary Steven Manoogian announced
they're going to be sending out debit cards
to people with stimulus money instead of checks
or direct deposits in some cases.
And he actually takes out and presents a debit
card to Trump with Trump's name on it.
And he seems to be explaining to Trump how
debit cards work, which actually is not super
surprising, but a debit card looks like with
your name on it.
Mr. President, now there's no money for you
on it.
This is a blank debit card, but I want you
to see what many Americans will now get so
that we can get their money to them even quicker.
And going forward, we think debit cards are
a safe and secure way of dealer delivering
refunds.
So I signed a letter again the next time we
get to send another letter.
Thank you, Steve.
Steve's had a great career.
Now, it is quite possible that Donald Trump
doesn't not know how debit cards work.
He's been a rich guy his whole life.
He may not understand how a debit card works.
But my question is whether this is actually
a good idea if you send someone a debit card.
How do you pay rent with that?
How do you pay your mortgage with that?
You often can't pay those with a debit card.
And when you.
Do you sometimes pay 3, 4, 5, even 6 percent
in fees?
So it seems like a strange idea to me, quite
frankly.
We certainly need to learn more about it.
And then here is Donald Trump once again calling
a female reporter rude and telling her that's
enough of you when she tries to follow up.
Go ahead, Mr. President.
Why haven't you announced a plan to get thirty
six million unemployed Americans back to work?
You're overseeing historic economic despair.
What's the plan?
I think we've announced a plan.
We're opening up our country.
Just a rude person.
You are.
We're opening up our country.
We're opening it up very fast.
The plan is that each state is opening and
it's opening up very effectively.
And you when you see the numbers, I think
even you will be impressed.
Which is pretty hard to impress you.
You are going to have a lot of his dollars
are not coming back.
And then very last thing, this is a bonus
from earlier in the day.
This was before Trump's cabinet meeting.
Trump was asked about Nancy Pelosi's comments
about him the day before that as a morbidly
obese man, as she put it, Donald Trump should
not be taking Hydroxy chloroquine.
And here's how Trump reacted.
These people are sick.
Pelosi is a sick woman's, got a lot of problems,
a lot of mental problems.
We're dealing with people that have to get
their act together for the good of the country.
OK.
So there it is.
A 73 year old rich guy who literally wears
orange clown makeup says that Nancy Pelosi
is the one who is mentally sick.
So these events are seen around the world.
The civilized world can't believe that this
is what's happening here.
We are the laughing stock.
And as I told you earlier this week, we are
increasingly pitted by the world because this
is the guy who's running the show.
People see this.
And even if a trampas thinks this is great,
what a great.
Trump taken Hydroxy chloroquine and calling
out reporters for nasty questions and all
of the stuff.
The world sees it.
They laugh and they pity us.
And it's a really major embarrassment.
It's a national nightmare that we'd really
need to end.
And we have the opportunity to end it just
over five months.